hi I'm Evan Carmichael walking through
on the dish and bass kevin today i'm
answering a question it's one of my
favorite gigs on website called online
games area and as you can see I'm a
little bit late in delivering this so
apologies to Chris who's website owner
and hopefully you get some good
information from this video so the point
of this gig is to review different
websites for entrepreneurs give some
feedback and hopefully they can use the
information to help grow their business
and also get some free promotion on my
youtube channel so the website is online
games area so we're going to check it
out here so this is the website and
basically lists a whole bunch of cool
games you can play and advertising is
likely the business model here and it's
actually not bad a lot of times these
sites are filled with advertisements
which make it not fun to play the games
but this one is tastefully done so you
can clearly see the gains but there are
still I'd supported here on the side and
I think it was a little bit below maybe
those are some inside pages from an SEO
perspective it's it's pretty good you
can tell from their content so the first
thing you think you see here is just the
games you don't see much content at all
but Chris has done a good job in
actually having content on every page
the content reads ok you know it's
designed more for the search engines
then for readers you can see you know
cool games and new games and best games
are highlighted and bolded but I think
for most people coming to see these
websites they're not looking to read
they're looking to play and so the
content is below the actual games I
think most people who will visit this
page will just go up here start playing
the games and not actually read the
content but it's a great idea to
actually have content on each page to
get them rank and if you do a search for
cool games which is what it is trying to
rank for you can see that it is number
three which is awesome the ones that are
ahead are cool games calm and cool math
games and so it's gonna be hard to
outrank those guys considering that they
have cool in their domain name so good
job on the SEO side so far so if I were
to come to the side if I go and click on
strategy first since I like the strategy
games so if I click on that one ideally
you can rank for every page on the site
and not just a home page as well so this
one
the title tag here we looking at
strategy games play strategy games
online and let's see what the keywords
are here it is bolded strategy games
online strategy games this month might
be a little harder to rank for let's see
strategy games online I was doing and
it's not on the first page so if
strategy games online is the important
keyword then we would probably want to
make sure we've got it here hopefully
this is an h1 tag you've piloted better
in your title tag move it closer to the
left then just having strategy ends up
there looks like there's enough content
on this page to be able to rank for and
you might want to think about having
better keyword research you know maybe
strategy games online is very
competitive and it's going to be hard to
rank for this page which is only a page
rank 2 on the inside so you might get
more traffic by changing around the
keyword or if I change around your
content and you're linking strategies
same thing would happen on each game so
let's click on this one first game here
on the strategy ultimate tank war so
this one is trying to rank for free tank
games or tenth games do a quick search
of free tank games and see what happens
free tank games and is not showing up on
the first page so again here we want to
have free tank games up in here he has
put it up in here right at the left so
that's that's great and still this is
good that he has content on this page a
lot of these guys and it's coming for
game sites or e-commerce stores you have
a big product of inventory and you don't
have enough content on each page to get
them right so kudos to Chris so far for
at least creating content on each page
it might be better targeted towards
keywords that will help him rank and
drive traffic or could also do some
better SEO in terms of link building to
get better links to the site now one
thing I did find I was quickly looking
at the Twitter profile here and so this
is his Twitter profile and he's got some
tweets looks like it was pretty active
in late March but nothing recently so
this is the last tweet of March 21st
right now we're looking at April 10th so
it's been a while since he's been active
on Twitter but one thing I found
interesting was doing a quick link
profile search in google the number one
link that came back was actually from a
tweet and so there's this guy named
Justin who linked to the site said check
check this one out that my friend made
want some cool new games online and so
it's interesting that that's coming up
as the first result in google for a link
search to the website and i'm wondering
if you might be able to get a better
improve your SEO by trying to get each
of those individual pages tweeted out
from your own account and then also
hopefully by other people who would find
those games interesting so something to
think about when you're planning out
your SEO you either have to target lower
quality keywords that won't drive as
much traffic but you have a good chance
of ranking for or improve your SEO both
on-site and off-site through link
building so that you do have a chance of
ranking for these little keywords these
better keywords so you've done a good
job on the homepage your ranking for
your number one keyword which is great
but the inside pages don't seem to be
ranking this one there's a big
opportunity thing to be able to make
make more money and drive more traffic
from better ranking better for those
keywords the next I want to look at
quickly is you use your experience so
the tank war was the number one strategy
game at least it was the first listed so
if I came to the home page and click
strategy I come here I'm going to click
on this one typically if I don't know
any of these I'll just click on the
first one and what surprised me a little
bit was it only had two stars and so
that seems a little bit low to me
especially for the first game and so I
would think about switching around the
order of the games on this page here so
you have the the best ones like I see an
option here top rated most played but I
would are automatically sort this by the
either top rated or most played some
kind of combination so that
you have people have a good user
experience if I come to this tank game
and I play and I don't enjoy it I'm
probably not going to come back to your
website again where if I come and I have
a good time and I really like the game
then I'm more likely to want to click
through on more of the games and see how
good they are so I recommend switching
the order the default order here round I
maybe even showing what the stars are
underneath and how many times have been
played just so I have a way to separate
them beyond just their name and the
picture and then the last thought I had
for this site is getting people to come
back somehow so it's great to somebody
lands in this website they may be bored
looking for a quick game to play online
and they land on one of your pages and
you'll hopefully have a good time but
they may not ever come back and so as
much as fossil with the website you want
to try to collect people's information
and give them a reason to come back to
the page and so if you had some kind of
newsletter here or an incentive to sign
up or some kind of membership then
people would hopefully leave their their
name and an email address and hopefully
give them a reason to want to do that
and then you have an excuse to be able
to contact them on an ongoing basis and
when you launch new games for then
there's a reason for them to come back
so for example if I really like strategy
games and you know I've played some of
these is a good number here but it's not
overwhelming it's not like i'm bombarded
with strategy games from here i might
run through these i may not come back
ever again or I may really like you know
tank games and that's the only one you
have and I may not ever come back but if
I left my name and email because you
promised me some bonus or membership or
some free download or free access to
special games you'll give me some reason
to sign up then whenever you launch a
new strategy game you could tell me and
then I would probably come and check it
out at least to see if I like it or not
and you know it's up to you to deliver
good quality in those emails if you send
me one or two that are not good i'm
probably going to unsubscribe from your
list but it's a quick way to be able to
capture information for people were
coming to the site and get them coming
back on an ongoing basis which will help
boost your numbers boost your ad revenue
boost your link profile boost your SEO
and so as much as fast you want to try
to build that relationship with people
and not just have it as a one-time visit
when they come in and hopefully they
don't forget to come back so those are
my initial thoughts Chris good job on
the site so far I might hang around for
a few minutes later and play one of
these games and see how good it is for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes want to do more for you and if
you have a thought about this website or
thought about your own business feel
free to leave in the comments section
below I always read those I always check
it out a love scene come in so thank you
and I'll see you on the next episode